I loved this movie you felt like a
Martin Riggs archetype getting a
redemption story because you don't get
the cop in the edge having a drama very
often a one true to andres perspective
in the script in particular well this is
we've said this is the kind of movie
that we love to make it's kind of movie
we love to watch we grew up on films
like this French Connection and justice
for all Taking of Pelham one two three
complicated you know
lock slash criminal stories that you
know where nothing is black and white
and and it has a social context to it
and it's really that story is really
about justice and his character
Candace character you know bridge
emotion and duty and that's really the
essence what the film is about so that's
the exciting part of it to us is that
it's the Matic American just the
character was so inspiring because look
at when you're on the front lines you
have to come up with a very specific
code to keep things right to make you
know that make sure you're sort of a
conducting yourself with an integrity in
a very convoluted process and Andre is
like better than any other cop he is
doing he's pulling that off in a way
that's putting him in the most difficult
situations that cops face and it was
just fascinating to like explore that
character and figure out how he actually
does that and this is that beautifully
rare mid budget police drama thriller
that I loved growing up on that people
claim can't be made and the deadly class
is an unadaptable comic you guys adapted
perfect I love what you did with the
class was the purpose of Agbo to make
these productions that can't get made
and try to make things happen minutes to
make things ever hear about and that
we're passionate about and that we love
I mean we grew up cinephiles that's
really our experience and the film
business we weren't shooting movies in
her backyard like Spielberg we were
watching movies and aunt and I were
having you know in depth heated
conversations about them when they were
over so we'd like to make films that
people can then not only enjoy and it's
exciting and it's got twists and turns
and the action is great the acting is
incredible and the script is great but
you can walk out after and have some
brain food and think
about you know the social context of
this movie and what it's trying to say
about the world today and how
complicated the world is because
everyone in this film every character
has a motivation for what they're doing
and you can either believe that
motivation or not but but you know
that's that's the way the world works is
that it's it's it's constant conflict
between ideas we are we're certainly
energized by the fact that we can take
the success that we realized with our
past several films with the Avenger
films they Captain America films and
partner with somebody like chadwick
boseman who can take that success as
well and pour it into movies that are
some people might consider is more
difficult to get made in its current
climate yeah I feel like Jean refills a
Trojan horse for important messages but
genre filmmakers are the Trojan horse
for important films like you can get
those movies made that don't work
getting made before and I feel like this
is this is one of those and I really I
love the whole ride now that the cast is
insane and it's always great to see
Taylor Kitsch on screen JK Simmons is a
delight and chatter Bozeman is just a
powerhouse here where any of those
actors in mind from the moment you
started in production oh yeah I mean
very I mean certainly Chadwick was the
the cornerstone to the whole thing and
we approached Chadwick very early on the
the Jo and I run the script exactly Joe
and I were introduced to this project
you know basically out of concept phase
where you know it was just it was just
an irresistible premise for a film where
a crime gets committed its nature and
severity is such that they are going to
actually lock down the entire island of
Manhattan for a manhunt over one night
and that sort of again being fans of
genre just that hook had us intrigued
and we began building from there and and
thinking about who this officer would be
at the center of the whole thing that we
can build this whole narrative around
I think Chadwick came up very early on
and we ended up floating an early draft
of the script by him and he ended up
being so intrigued he wanted to come out
and co-produce with us which wasn't made
as incredible yeah yeah with the Boston
Marathon this is a very similar story to
like a real-life incident like we shut
down Boston and we had a manhunt and
push people out was it was there any
real-life influences in your life that
inspired you to want to make a movie
like this did anything occur that you
wanted to make a police thriller so
gritty and visceral again I think it's
just it
these kinds of films allow for certain
themes to be examined that you can't
examine in other kinds of movies
especially current themes and I think
that you know what's fascinating about
the story is that it's a pressure cooker
and that that you know there's certain
there's a plausibility that not a
weeknight you know that with that said
that the sort of severity of this crime
that you could potentially close
Manhattan from one don't like four or
five in the morning and try to flush out
some very very important criminals and I
think that ultimately that at the end of
the day is which rose to the project
yeah
also I think you know we grew up our you
know we grew up in Cleveland and sort of
a very politically complicated time
economically complicated time and our
dad was an activist politician and very
much into sort of championing the
disenfranchised and so I think from a
young age we've always been very CUTE
into power and the abuses of power and
what do you do about that and I think
you know the police are one of the most
interesting areas you can look at that
sort of the issue of abuse of power
because there they are police are so
powerful they're they're empowered to do
so much in our society and so I think
that I think that's one deep-seated
emotional draw that we had to this
project is looking at modern-day police
corruption in in a very original fresh
way that I think is important in terms
of understanding our society we once
talked about how framing for comedy
interprets differently didn't how you
use the frame to tell a lot a story in
just a single frame has anything from
making a superhero film informed how you
go forward with cherry and the next
thing in the next thing
oh well yeah I think I know I don't know
we always say that you know when young
filmmakers ask us what can we do to
become a director say just get-get out
your iPhone and shoot because you know
and a be a great carpenter you should
build a lot of tables right you know
build better tables every time you make
a table so there's anything we took away
from working on those films the process
is so intense and you're constantly
thinking and working that muscle in your
brain as a filmmaker
that you know that you know moving
forward yes you're developing techniques
that that you know you haven't had
before and we're able to apply those to
you know films whether we're producing
films like 21 bridges or directing films
like cherry and and we've also created a
family with our crew yeah and and they
move with us from project to project and
a lot of the people that were very close
to from you know the seven or eight
years we spent at Marvel worked on 21
bridges and are working on cherry and
that I think it's a critical part of it
because it is really ultimately the
other day directing is an exceedingly
collaborative a job and and you keep
what you won't succeed without you know
the brilliant minds around you they're
helping you try to succeed I think one
other thing as I think about it is also
this this idea that with cinema anything
is possible you know we we grew up comic
book fans and at the time comic books
were a fringe pop cultural sort of
experience right and now we've been able
to make movies at their at their
grandest level based upon these ideas
and these characters and these stories
and just to sort of see that arc in our
lives happen I think it really just
speaks to the fact that like yeah moving
forward as filmmakers you know just a
recommitment to this idea that anything
is possible
has there been any major adjustments and
how you shape things going from the
infinite budget and infinite time of a
Marvel property to something more
contained like cherry has been or is the
shorthand just there I mean the short
hands there certainly and we've spent
years doing indie films and television
so you know our brains are adept at
working quickly when we need to and you
know I think that you know with 21
bridges in which area we're getting
everything that we want to get yeah
irrespective of the limitations and
limitations on budget drive creativity
they really do and and you know at some
of our best work has been done under
incredible duress and and so we we look
forward to the you know the moments when
you get put inside a financial box
because typically you'll you'll you'll
make very creative decisions in order to
solve problems well and I also had this
how much money we had making the Avenger
movies you know at some point you always
run out of money sure somebody comes in
wait a second exactly there's that line
now the internet was shocked and
surprised by Tom Hollands haircut for
cherry which I loved seeing that
insanity was there anything on this
experience that's shocked and surprised
you yet hasn't been performance a day of
shooting on Jerry I'm cher Alyssa that
was shocking or surprising oh yeah I
mean the whole thing is shocking and
surprising I read that you you read the
book I mean it's a very controversial
book it's about the opioid crisis we
were from Ohio area the country it's
considered ground zero for the crisis
that a lot of people close to us died
because of it and you know so I think
the subject matter is is difficult
dealing with PTSD the Iraq war the
legacy of that we're on abused opioid
prescribing allottee you know it's a
it's a very complicated character I will
say this Tom Hahn is killing it yes just
kicking ass in this role and we couldn't
be more proud of them and it's as
complicated a role as an actor
complained he's just doing a spectacular
job I can't wait I love this film I
can't wait to see Jerry I appreciate you
guys making movies that I love to see
and the ones that people aren't making
right now so I love this one thank you
very much thank you thanks a lot thank
you thanks